(man) the sharks are back,
in an all-New season
of "Shark tank,"
where Hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
It's potentially the best
product we've ever seen.
Here's my offer.
I'd like to take
the $90,000 you want
and add a zero to it.
Now we're at $900,000.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for...
(voice breaking)
I work so hard.
Or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Who will bid the highest?
It doesn't work that way!
I haven't seen this before
in the "shark tank."
It's sink...
(Robert) Wow.
Seth Macfarlane, baby.
Or swim.
None of us are interested
except for Lori.
This is such a warm,
inviting place.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
First into the tank
is ginelle mills,
who set out to solve
a problem she faced as a mom.
♪♪
Hi. I'm ginelle.
I am the owner of cool wazoo.
I'm here seeking $65,000
in exchange for 25% equity
in my company.
When my daughter
was Younger,
she was burned
on a park swing.
And I looked everywhere
for a product
that would protect her
from the heat of the swing,
and I couldn't find one.
So that's when I decided
to create one.
This was my diaper bag
at the time.
It was overstuffed
with all these products.
I was carrying around this
bulky shopping cart cover,
this restaurant
high chair cover,
this car shade,
and this way-Too-Small
changing pad.
I couldn't fit another
product in this diaper bag.
I couldn't even fit the diapers,
and it was a diaper bag.
And then I had an "Aha!"
moment.
What if I took
all these products
and made them
into one product
and incorporated my swing idea
into that same product?
Wouldn't that be cool?
(laughs)
Well, here it is.
It's called cool wazoo.
This is the first cover
with core material
on the inside
that redirects that heat
back to its source,
and it does five things.
It is the swing cover,
the restaurant high chair
cover,
the shopping cart cover,
and a car shade,
and... a changing pad.
I'm looking for a shark
who wants to make money
while making lives easier
and safer
for moms and children
everywhere.
Who wants to be cool with me?
Ginelle, 35 years ago,
when I was 5 years old...
(laughter)
I didn't have any of this crap,
and I somehow survived.
Who's buying all this junk?
Moms buy this stuff.
They're concerned
about the germs,
and now, as my daughter was,
I was concerned about the heat.
So that's why I meshed
the two together.
Why don't you show him
your packaging?
(mark) Now, ginelle, there's
other competitors, right?
Because I know my wife
has used other products.
(Robert) There is?
These are some
of my competitors.
There's not one product
that does five things.
When my daughter was burned,
it was 80 degrees outside.
What were you doing?
Swinging her on the swing.
I put her on.
It was 80 degrees--
Wasn't she howling
at the moon?
No--Well, you put her down.
(imitates babbling)
You know?
I'm like, "ugh.
Just swing," you know?
Just like--
(sharks laughing)
I mean, something like that.
I mean... (laughs)
You see smoke coming up,
she's on fire.
(Robert) Wow.
(speaks indistinctly)
I bought online
one of those laser guns
that measure--
You shot her?
(laughter)
That measures the surface
temperat--
I know what you're
talking about.
That measures surface
temperatures, yes.
You--You direct it, and it
tells you the temp.
So you're now shooting the seat
with a laser
to get the temperature.
Yes, because I couldn't
believe it was that hot.
I can't believe you go from
that to buying a laser gun.
Yeah, because I felt bad.
I had a little bit of luck
back last may.
The product
was on the "today" show
With Kathie Lee and hoda.
And it was on for about
40-Second airtime--
How many did you sell
from those 40 seconds?
Well, I didn't have
any inventory.
So, online,
did you take orders
even though
you didn't have inventory?
I'd rolled into production,
the "today" show hit,
and when I got
those orders back,
85% of those cool wazoos
were wrong.
That first run that I did,
85% of it
went back to the factory
because they didn't
really know
how to work with
this kind of material.
Did they refund your money
when you returned it?
They didn't refund the money.
(Lori) But how many people
ordered, anyway?
About $14,000 in sales.
What happened after that?
Well, I didn't really know
how to capitalize on that.
This past december, I was
on the show "the doctors,"
and it was
a christmas special.
Wow!
The first time,
she wasn't in a position
to take advantage of it.
I'm sure when you were going
on "the doctors," you said,
"I don't want this
to happen again."
What happened?
Good point.
Well, I was kind of
out of money at that point.
They wanted to give
everyone in the audience
250 cool wazoos,
so that's where
my inventory went.
I basically gave it away.
For free?
For free.
And what'd you get back
in return?
Nothing, because the format
of the show kind of...
wow.
Changed a little bit
at the last minute.
That's not a great
business decision.
(Kevin) You know what?
I know. That's--
That was a bad--
You got cool wa-Screwed.
What are your sales?
In the last 12 months,
my sales have been $20,000,
but I have had
zero inventory.
My efforts right now
have not been on sales,
because I'm moving
my production overseas,
because it's costing me too much
money to make them here.
How much is it costing you
to make them here?
It's costing me--
Hold your breath.
$30 to make one.
Wow.
(gasps loudly)
♪♪
How much is it costing you
to make them here?
It's costing me--
Hold your breath.
$30 to make one.
Wow.
(gasps)
Yeah, it's killing me,
okay?
Shocking.
I'm retailing them
for $64.95.
Retail?
What about wholesale?
And wholesaling--
Hold your breath--
$32.50.
You're making $2 and fif--
That's why I'm not
selling them!
(Robert) Come on!
That's why--
I'm not kidding you.
Are you a Charity?
So, Yeah.
Where do you see
your costs going?
From $30 to what if you move
production overseas?
Okay, so I've spent
the last year,
um, really focusing on
not just the cost,
but also the quality.
(Robert) How much?
$11.36.
Nice.
If you're doing this
full time--
Your husband supporting
this effort with you?
Does your husband own
half the business?
He has funded the business
100%.
And how much have you lost
on it so far?
$96,000.
Yo!
Whoa!
That's a lot of burnt heinies.
Wow.
Well, okay, so, it--
How much more pain
can he sustain?
(laughs)
(chuckles)
he's very tolerable.
I mean, he's--
He is supportive 100%.
If you lose another $100,000,
he'd be okay?
I think if I gave him
a nice smile, he might.
(laughs)
(Kevin) Well...
people like this product,
and everything I've said--
I have not had one return
on the product.
Ginelle, you're on a--
You're on a wonderful journey.
Really?
You're... (laughs)
Journey to where?
You're saving babies' behinds.
You've lost $100,000.
You have
a very supporting partner.
But it's--It's a long road.
I'm not sure that I want
to join you.
On the wonderful journey?
Uh, it's not for me.
I'm out.
♪♪
You make great faces.
I gotta give you that.
(laughter)
I can't join you
on the wonderful journey.
I really can't, because
I think it ends in tragedy
with grown Men weeping--me.
(laughter)
I'm out.
Wow. Oh, man.
Two sharks are out.
Daymond, will you be
joining her on the journey?
(chuckles) Well, I think that,
um, you've learned a lot.
But you're not as seasoned
as a c.E.O.
That I would like
to work with.
I'm out.
Okay, just back up.
I have orders.
I have a canadian distributor
that I have signed
an agreement with,
and they are verbally saying
2,000 to 3,000 to start.
But they did give me
a purchase order
for the first 1,000.
I think you are great,
and I think that you will
solve problems, and solutions.
I think that maybe
this one won't be your hero,
but there will be
a hero in your future.
I'm out.
(stammers) Let me show you
how easy this is to work.
The problem is not
the product.
The problem is
it's not a company yet.
I have to get a return
on my time.
It's not just on the--
the money.
The money's actually
the easier part.
The Harder part is time.
To get you and educate you
and put you through all this
so you don't make
as many mistakes,
because otherwise,
with my money,
you're gonna go through
an ONGOING learning process.
And because of that, I'm out.
Hmm.
Everyone's out?
(inhales)
(voice breaking)
This means a lot.
I have put--
I work so hard.
I'm up at 2:00,
3:00, 4:00.
I don't--I have
entrepreneur hours.
I mean, it's--It's been crazy,
and I underestimated
the time that it was
gonna take me
to get to China.
I didn't know it was
gonna take that hard.
I have been working--
Although it seems like
I just launched,
I have been working on This
for four years almost.
It took me two years
to design it
and to source the material.
But I took everything that
I was frustrated with these,
and I made it better.
I have had many tears
over this product.
(voice cracks) I...
it's...
ginelle,
I'm gonna come back in.
I really like you.
(sniffles)
And I really believe in you.
And I can see that
you're gonna put your heart
and soul into this.
And I'll give you
the $65,000
for a 25% stake.
And I will help you
to get the price down
and to manufacture
this better.
Wow, I would have
taken 50%.
No. That's it.
That's it. What do you say?
Say "Yes" Before--
Yes, of course. Yes!
(laughing)
Ah!
Thank you so much.
We'll make it work.
(laughs) Thank--
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Ginelle, great job.
(daymond) Ginelle,
you are deadly.
Your smile gets your husband
and your tears get Lori.
(laughs)
I'll tell you. Amazing.
Congrats, ginelle.
Congratulations.
Thanks.
(Kevin) What's the difference
between her
and the 100,000 entrepreneurs
that'll cry
if you ask them how hard
they've worked?
Lori, did you invest in her
because she cried?
No, it wasn't because
she cried.
This cannot become--
It was because she showed
such extreme passion for this.
I liked who she was,
and I also think
it's a good product, and I--
why didn't you get 51%
and get control?
Her journey's
all over the map.
I am not always about
taking control of things.
Let me run out there
and fix it for you.
(laughs) No, I don't want you
to run out there
and fix it for me.
She'd love to see me.
I've worked so hard for this,
and now that I've got
this deal,
I can see what I need
to do next,
and I'm gonna work
even Harder.
'cause I'm not gonna
disappoint Lori.
In season 3, we watched
Barbara lampugnale
make a deal with Lori Greiner
for her multi-Functional
nail polish, nail Pak.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Let's see what they're
up to now.
♪♪
(Barbara) Thanks to Lori,
here we are today
at ulta beauty
with the opportunity
to have nail Pak
in retail stores
everywhere.
This is the creative team
at ulta beauty.
Welcome to ulta beauty.
This is Barbara lampugnale.
Hello, Barbara.
Nice to meet you.
Very nice to meet you.
I knew we had a Winner
when we saw our tremendous
success on qvc and online.
So, we're here today
to show you
the nail Pak,
Barbara's fabulous creation.
We've already done
50,000 bottles
and 3/4 of a million
in sales.
What this is, is it has
nail polish on the top,
and when you open this up...
(woman) Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
There's pads and remover
in here.
My hope is
that they love it.
My heart's racing about
a thousand miles a minute.
We would love to carry
nail Pak
in our 500 stores
across the country
and online.
(laughing)
Goosebumps. Thank you!
(Lori)
She did an amazing job.
She just went in there.
She was confident.
She cinched it.
She did fantastic.
Thank you so much.
You're so welcome.
I feel like I should
hug you.
You're so welcome.
Wonderful.
It's like
an Easter egg hunt.
Where is it? Where is it?
(speaks indistinctly)
Oh, my gosh! (gasps)
(laughing)
God! It looks so great!
I know. You need to pinch me.
I just--
(laughing)
I cannot believe This is real.
I can hardly believe
that it was just
a few short weeks ago
that we were pitching to ulta,
and now here we are,
physically in the store
with our products on the shelf.
It's amazing.
I can't thank you enough.
Oh, my god.
I just can't believe
This is happening.
And so fast. It's crazy.
I don't know where I would be
without "Shark tank."
Quite literally, it's more
than just a tv show.
It is sincerely something that
has made my dreams come True.
♪♪
(bird screeches)
My name is Bruce Gaither.
I live in Sylmar, california
with my wife and children.
♪♪
I've been around horses
all my life.
I was a professional
polo Player for about 30 years.
But I've hung up my mallet
for the time being
to become a full-Time dad.
Get set... go!
Now I'm
a professional horse trainer.
I give riding lessons as well.
I have
several a-list clientele,
who, uh, have become
my friends in the process.
Thank you, sir.
I love working outside,
and my barn is pretty much
my office.
But there are some drawbacks,
and those drawbacks
are what inspired my product.
I've been working
on this project for five years.
We have it on store shelves,
But nobody knows what it is.
I'm not a marketing genius,
I'm a cowboy.
We need help,
and investment and support
from the sharks
means everything to myself
and everything to my family.
♪♪
Hello, folks.
My name is Bruce Gaither.
This is biscuit.
And my company
is no fly Cone.
I'm looking for an investment
of $25,000
for a 15% stake in my company.
Now, you've all heard
the saying,
"build a better mousetrap,
and the world
will beat a path
to your door."
Well, I've built
a better flytrap.
No fly Cone is a nontoxic,
Cone-Shaped flytrap
that catches them on the inside
so you don't have to see them.
The Cone is placed over
a natural attractant,
provided by biscuit.
Nothing works better.
It's a simple solution.
You take your flytrap,
your no fly Cone,
and you set it...
over a scooper.
Come back later, and you
see how well it works.
(Robert) EW!
(Lori laughs)
Now, the reason I came up
with This
is because my office
is the barn,
which is haunted with flies
because of the dogs
and the horses.
So, I designed
an all-Natural flytrap,
and right away,
we were successful,
catching them where they
feed and breed.
With your investment
and your connections,
we can make no fly Cone
the trusted standard
for controlling flies
in no time.
What questions do you have
for me?
How is that different
than, like,
a no-Pest strip
that you would hang?
Well, the strips
have an external glue.
Well, you see the flies
that they accumulate.
With this,
you don't see the flies
until you actually look
to see what you've caught.
It requires dog excrement
as the attractant.
(Robert) Is that True?
Yes, sir.
(daymond) So, the dog
has to defecate outside,
and you put the cap over this,
and that attracts the flies.
But if you clean up the dog's
mess and put it away...
You got it, daymond.
You--You're kind of
creating the problem
by leaving the poop outside,
aren't you?
When you pick up
your dog poop,
there's gonna be residue
on the grass,
and there's residue
in your scooper.
Does this attract other things
besides flies?
People catch mosquitoes
with it,
people catch gnats with it.
Um, there's a lot of different
uses for the trap.
Wh--
Lot of different applications.
Seth Macfarlane, baby.
Hey, you guys doing
a tv show?
No way!
How are you?
I'm good. I'm good.
Bruce, who is this guy?
This is, uh,
my Buddy Seth Macfarlane.
Welcome, Seth.
How's it going?
Creator of "Family guy"
over here.
(as stewie) You know,
I put a lot of money
into that landmark
theatre business.
Didn't do so well.
Oh, stewie, come on, man!
(laughter)
Oh, stewie!
Love that show.
(normal voice)
Thank you very much.
Seth, you look like you're
18 years old, for god sake.
You are so--Oh, god,
now I love it here.
(Lori laughs)
Seth, you weren't just
walking by.
(chuckles)
So, what brings you?
Uh, Bruce is
a friend of mine.
I actually take horseback
Riding lessons from Bruce.
And, you know, he--He showed me
how this thing works,
and, you know,
it's not just flies.
It's small children...
(laughter)
Uh, bad feelings.
It just--It attracts them all.
It's great. Yeah.
Seth saw me develop the trap.
Well, Bruce, you have
a very big fly right here
who can help you
with this situation.
(Lori laughs)
Why--Why do you need us?
I ha--
I'm not allowed to do
anything for abc.
(laughter)
If I ever write
a really funny cartoon,
I'm gonna hand it
to Seth and say, "here."
But right now I have, like,
five amazing people
in front of me
that can help me
get this on the market.
What are your sales
for the last year?
Only 3,000 traps.
Seth, uh, where do you live?
I-I don't like flies
in my house.
Do you use this
in your house?
What's my address?
I'm not gonna tell you
where I live.
(laughter)
But do you use these
in your house?
Yeah, I-I don't have a dog.
He's your spokesman,
and he doesn't even have a dog?
If I did, I'd be
the first guy in line.
What I'm not relating to is,
is that I have to have...
dog excrement
to make it work.
(Robert)
This is a qvc product.
I could see you on air
with the little dog poop
selling this.
(laughter)
They've sold worse crap
than this.
(laughter)
(Lori) Oh, come on!
Oh, boo! Bad!
You know, Bruce,
I'm with biscuit on this one.
He's--he's waiting
for something right now.
I don't know what it is.
(laughter)
He's--
I just have no interest
in it.
(Robert laughs)
I'm out.
Thank you, Kevin.
(as stewie) You're not
a very nice man.
(laughter)
They told me you were
not a nice man.
(laughing)
Bruce, I don't have
any connections
in this side of the world,
so I-I don't think
I'm the guy to help you,
so I'm out.
And it's because he picked on
landmark. I wouldn't never s--
thank you, mark.
(normal voice)
Oh, wow! See?
You're regretting
this already.
No--
So, Bruce,
two sharks are out.
Was it a good idea
to bring Seth or not?
(laughs)
Well, I'll tell you,
it was a lot more fun
than being out here
by myself, so Yeah.
Yeah. (laughs)
Hey, you know, I'll tell you,
the only reason I'm not out yet
is because you brought Seth.
Ugh. I, uh... (sighs)
I just don't even know if I can
help you even with Seth.
I'm out.
(mouths word)
Well, I'm not gonna hold
Seth against you.
This is a--such a warm,
inviting place.
(mark) Yeah.
(laughs)
What love is in this room.
(Lori) I commend you
for coming up with something.
You had a problem,
you created a solution,
and that's great.
The problem for me is,
is I can't get past
how it works.
It's a personal turn-off.
I--if it had another
type of attractant,
then it might be
more appealing.
Well, let's go
for chicken bones.
Chicken bones. (laughs)
I'm sorry. I'm out.
(Robert) I got to be honest
with you, Bruce.
I really can't add
a lot of value.
(imitating Boris karloff)
And the grinch's heart
grew Three sizes that night.
(laughs)
Bruce, I'm sorry.
I'm gonna be out.
Thank you, Robert.
I-I blame myself.
No, no.
You probably should.
This was my fault.
Yeah, Seth, we're all
blaming you.
You probably should, Seth.
This was my fault.
This was a terrible idea.
What a disaster.
No, it was wonderful.
Not really.
Thanks for coming out.
Thank you, folks.
Thank you very much.
All right, Seth,
pleasure, man.
(Robert) Pleasure, guys.
Gentlemen and lady.
Come on, biscuit.
(laughter)
Thanks for trying, Buddy.
I really appreciate it.
I didn't--I was--
I was no help to you.
It was actually a good idea.
Not really. So bad.
At one point, there was
a-a fly crawling
down the side
of Mr. Wonderful's face
as he was talking, and it
just kind of made its way
into his mouth, and--
Like the bad guy from
"raiders of the lost ark,"
and he didn't do anything.
He just sat there,
kept talking.
I don't know if it went
down his throat or what.
But clearly, not only
does he need this thing,
but I don't even think
he's human.
(laughs)
♪♪
Next into the tank
is Michael tseng,
who believes he has
the potential to make millions
with his household innovation.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Michael tseng,
and my product is called
platetopper.
I'm seeking $90,000
in exchange
for 5% of my company.
Millions of households
already use
plastic containers
and plastic wrap,
but there are huge problems
with these products.
Plastic lids and containers
always go missing.
Saran wrap
is an inconvenient mess.
Platetopper transforms
your plates at home
into airtight
Food storage containers.
Here's how it works.
Simply grab the handle
and press down.
And the airtight Seal
is so strong...
(Kevin) Oh.
You can suspend a plate
in midair.
It works on circular plates,
grandma's favorite China,
even your kitchen counter.
To release the Seal,
lift the pull tab,
and your food is ready
to serve.
Platetopper
is microwave-Safe,
to prevent messy splattering
and to keep food warm.
And cleanup is a breeze,
because platetopper
is dishwasher-safe.
And watch this.
You can finally organize
your kitchen cabinets
at home,
because platetoppers
nest neatly
for efficient storage.
But wait. There's more.
(laughter)
Sharks, if you invest
right now,
I'll throw in Three
New Sizes absolutely free.
(Lori laughs)
The platetopper mini...
(Kevin) Wow.
The platetopper tall...
(Kevin) Ooh.
(daymond) ahh!
And the famous cake topper.
Ahh!
Wow!
Sharks, I need your help
to fill
massive purchase orders
from two of the world's
largest retailers.
Join me,
and let's make platetopper
into a household brand
right now.
Sharks, here are
the platetoppers.
Thanks, Michael.
Absolutely.
Lori.
Thank you.
Wow!
Kevin.
Isn't that amazing?
Comes off so easy.
(Lori) So what are these
major retailers that you're in?
You might as well jump
right to that.
Uh, the product has been
on qvc since March,
and it's still on,
and on walmart's Web site
since may.
So no actual retailers
in the store?
This has been just only
on web sites?
Correct.
This is such a good idea.
Thank you.
It's by far the most elegant way
to cover food,
as opposed to covering it
with a disposable...
(Kevin) Oh, I hate that.
I'm always ripping it.
Trash product.
Mike, you--
(Robert) Michael, how did you
come up with it?
I came up with the product
over seven years ago
when I was at home from college
over holiday break.
I was doing a lot of work
in the kitchen
and just envisioned
a suction plate dome.
And eventually I combined that
with a microwave plate cover
and created the platetopper
you see today.
So you had
no engineering background
or product background?
Well, I did just come up
with the idea randomly,
but I studied electrical
engineering in college
at princeton university.
Oh. A princeton guy.
And then I went on
to study
biomedical engineering,
and last year I graduated
from medical school
from U.C.S.F.
And, Mr. Wonderful, feel free
to call me Dr. Platetopper.
(sharks laugh)
Are you a doctor, Michael?
I'm a doctor on paper.
I'm not a practicing physician
right now,
because I've taken
the last year off
to completely dedicate myself
to launching
the platetopper product line.
I see there's a patent there.
Yes. There's
a utility patent here.
Under your best case scenario,
in the next 12 months,
how much can you sell?
So right now, uh,
purchase orders
Have totaled over $1 million.
That's over four months.
Of that, I get paid wholesale
$500,000.
Michael,
I like what you're doing.
Okay.
And I think what you need
is a financier.
Absolutely.
Because, you know,
when I talk about
owning 5% equity
in a business,
I don't even get up
in the morning for that.
It's irrelevant.
Mm-hmm. Right.
So I'm not interested
in your equity,
but I am interested in you.
I'm gonna reverse your deal.
I'm gonna say, you want
$90,000? You've got it.
Okay.
Pay me a 5% royalty.
And you keep 100%
of what you own
for the big score
when you sell this
to a major player one day.
I totally love this product.
I'll even get on qvc and say
it's great on my chicken.
So, Mike--
Okay. Well, thank you,
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you for that offer.
It is an offer on the table,
and I will consider it
as I listen to other offers.
Excellent.
Great answer.
What I love about you
is you're very, very smart.
Um, you know, you're slick.
Also, I think
a little obnoxious.
Wait, there's more.
You're a little greedy,
and I can't wait
to be your partner.
What was your strategy
coming here
offering us 5% for $90,000?
I mean, you know, obviously,
that's--That's crap, right?
I know th--I--
the relatively low portion
of the equity
is because I want to retain
as much of the company
as possible, obviously.
All roads lead to Mr. Wonderful
in that scenario.
How many did you sell
your first time on qvc?
How many units?
It was 6,080 single units.
But what I'd--
what I'd like to say is
on qvc, they did
an initial test run
with $60,000 worth of retail.
(daymond) Mm-hmm.
A few months later,
they ordered
$1 million worth
of retail goods.
So... the same possibility
exists with walmart.
So I think we've established
this guy's the real deal, right?
(Lori) Here's my offer.
I'd like to take
the $90,000
and add a zero to it.
Yes. (exhales deeply)
So now we're at $900,000--
Offer.
Yes.
Ooh.
(daymond) All right.
♪♪
I'd like to take the $90,000
and add a zero to it.
Lori has offered Michael
10 times more money
than he asked for.
So now we're at $900,000--
Offer.
Yes.
(Robert) Ooh.
(daymond) All right.
For 30%.
I would like us to do
our own infomercial rollout.
Mm-hmm.
And I have all the connections
to all of the top retailers
around the world.
Michael, she's giving you
a $3 million valuation,
all right?
That is a phenomenal offer,
but what I'm curious is--
I know it's going to take
more than $900,000.
What is the financing like
on the back end?
As it's working,
I'll keep funding.
(daymond) Here's why
Lori's not necessarily
the right partner for you,
because you already are on qvc.
We're not even talking about
getting on qvc, daymond.
If you didn't have that...
Mm-Hmm.
Then I can see that she's
giving you something else
that we may not be able
to do...
Yeah.
Because she has an immediate--
Turn the switch.
Mm-hmm.
But... you're there.
(Lori) That's all fine,
daymond,
but he has an offer
on the table right now...
I know it.
From me for $900,000.
And he has a second one
for $1 million for 25%, Lori.
Pardon me?
Oh. Silence.
Well--
He has a second offer
for $1 million for 25%.
Bang!
(Lori) But he doesn't have...
okay.
Any of the connections
or the pipeline
or the factories
or all the things...
Mm-Hmm.
That I'm offering you.
What is she--
What is she talking about?
And I've offered you more,
because I said we'd start
with $900,000.
I offered $1 million.
You know, I started
exactly like you.
I'm just you 17 years later
with all those connections.
I think you know I'm
the right partner for you...
Mm-Hmm.
Because I know how to do
exactly what you want to do.
Bull crap. You know,
Lori's great at what she does,
but she thinks she's great at
everything every one of us does.
Um...
(laughs) Don't listen
to the little noise over there.
(Kevin) Let's just look
at these two offers--
$900,000 for 30%.
Right.
$1 million for 25%.
But of them, you understand,
steals your equity.
Okay.
Because This is gonna be
worth a fortune one day,
and you gave up.
Michael, are you seriously
considering Kevin's offer?
Kevin, right now, based on
these excellent offers
on the table, I'm gonna
respectfully decline your offer.
(Robert) Thank you.
You want to give up equity?
Bam!
Shut up, Kevin.
So right now I just want to
get to the valuation.
I do have a valuation in mind
that's, uh,
a little bit different than
the one I stated initially.
My product--
It's gone from $60,000
to $1 million in retail sales
in a few months.
And it's been proven
on qvc--
Yes, but there's 4,000 other
products that went to zero.
I'm just saying,
there's obviously utility
for every single household
in America
that has circular plates.
But I'll tell you one--
Let him finish.
I'm saying
that my valuation--
I want it to reflect
the potential.
Are you gonna put
a number out there, Mike?
Yeah, but, Mike, because--
Michael, you were gonna get
to a number, weren't you?
I-I'm saying these other
products grow
to $100 million products.
Okay. Guys--
(Robert) No, but, Michael,
you must have a number in mind.
What's your number?
I'm getting irritated.
It's a little slippery to me,
the way you're acting.
S--
'cause, listen,
you got a number, man.
Yeah.
Let's not play games.
Daymond,
I'm--I'm honestly not
trying to be slick or Sly--
Just get to the number, man.
Say it then.
I'm not trying to be
slick or Sly.
I'm just letting everybody
field their offer before--
Okay, you have one offer
for $900,000.
Before I--
just say the number, man.
If I were
a used car salesman,
I wouldn't say,
"here's the lowest I'll go."
I would negotiate.
Michael, I don't disagree
with your strategy.
I'm not being--
I'm not trying to be negative.
If I know one thing,
it's to say less
than it is to say more.
So I am not gonna disclose
what my magic number is.
All right, Mike,
you know what?
You're starting to rub me
the wrong way. I'm out.
(Robert) WHOA!
Whoa!
It's a slick Willie thing.
You know, dancing around--
"Well, maybe. Hold on.
I'm say--"
So, daym--
I-I'm out. You don't need
to speak to me anymore.
I--
(Kevin) Well,
that's interesting, Mike.
So I'll speak
to Mr. Wonderful,
and may--And daymond
might overhear me.
So I really appreciated
daymond's offer
of $1 million for 25%.
Listen.
My gut Feeling is saying
This would not be a great
partnership for you and I.
Hmm.
Because I practice business
another way, all right?
Okay.
So I should shut up,
because I'm not in this anymore.
Uh, so--Uh, daymond, I'm--
(Kevin) Y-You know why you're
running into trouble here?
You came with a valuation
of $1.8 million.
Yeah.
And then you're not
honoring it anymore.
(Robert) he's negotiating.
I-I'm field--
I'm fielding these offers.
(Kevin) You have
three sharks left.
You have reduced
your probability of success
by at least two out of five.
You better get focused
on the other sharks
that are still in the deal.
I want to hear
from the other sharks.
And, Lori, I--
your offer's great,
so we're gonna talk about it.
You know,
I'm gonna step back.
Are you taking your offer
off the table, Lori?
I'm curious just to say,
what if I rolled it back?
What if I went back
to the $90,000
for the 5%
as you walked in?
Seems to me like you're
more comfortable with that.
So, Michael, let me tell you
what's happening now.
You had an offer.
(laughing)
No, it's nothing
to laugh about, my friend.
Okay.
You're losing offers.
You're losing money.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
You're losing!
When are you gonna shut up
and take an offer?
(Robert) Here's where I'm at.
For me, the risk is
the product doesn't sell.
(snaps fingers)
$1 million gone.
$500,000 gone.
All of a sudden,
you're into negative cash.
That's my worry.
Are you gonna make
an offer, Robert?
Michael,
I-I can't help you
with the retail part.
Okay.
Um...
uh, so, in terms--
Before you--before--
I'm out.
You do realize you haven't
even given
the remaining two sharks
your valuation yet?
I mean, at this point, you gotta
stop playing the games.
What is the number?
I-I'm simply waiting for
offers to be on the table.
All right. I'm gonna go
to the bathroom, man...
if you keep waiting...
or something, you know?
They keep getting smaller.
That's what's actually
happening here.
You only have two sharks left.
I'm gonna--
I'll give--I'll put out--
I'll throw out a number.
You guys have pushed me.
Okay.
Um, I'll--I'll describe
the offer
that I was originally
going to make,
which was $750,000
in exchange for 5%
of the company.
Here we go with this crap.
And that's a valuation
of $15 million.
Wait a minute.
You asked for $90,000 for 5%.
Now you've changed it
to $750,000?
I haven't changed it.
I've said that was
what I was originally gonna
come into the tank with.
Why did you come in
with $90,000 for 5%?
Switch and bait.
Why are you doing that? Why?
I'm not--
We actually may watch a guy
with a fantastic business
walk out of here
with nothing pretty soon.
Potentially the best product
we've ever seen.
♪♪
Wow. We actually may watch a guy
with a fantastic business
walk out of here
with nothing pretty soon.
Potentially the best product
we've ever seen.
(mark) Let me ask
a simple question.
What is the value to you
for a line of credit
in the event
your projections are met?
(sighs and clicks tongue)
I would need to call--
Can I call my person?
Sure. Let him make
his phone call.
Really?
Yes. Yeah.
Time is money.
Go ahead. Just make it quick.
(exhales deeply)
guys, you wanna deal
with this guy every day?
No. I wouldn't
deal with this guy.
He went from $90,000 for 5%
to $750,000 for 5%.
You're telling me
he's accurate?
Well, I don't know
if he's accurate,
but there's definitely
something there.
(cell phone chimes)
(man) Hey, Mike.
Can you talk to
one of your c.E.O.S?
Can you pull them
into your office right now
to help me with this
sort of valuation?
Sure, Yeah. One second.
He's playing a ridiculous game.
No, he's just precise.
It's definitely something there,
but don't lie.
I mean, this is when
he's in his best behavior.
Imagine when he's a partner.
They're essentially saying,
"look, you're gonna need
"money in the future
in order to finance,
uh, purchase orders."
Mm-hmm.
What if they were to give me
a $10 million line of credit?
Essentially, how much equity
would I give them in return?
He came in and made
a strategic decision
that he would give up
a small portion of equity
for a small amount of money
in order to get
the relationship.
I throw guys like this
out of my office.
I throw them out
of the window.
Like, this is just ridiculous.
This is--
This is ridiculous.
(under breath) okay.
Okay, Michael, what's happened
here in the "shark tank"
is rather remarkable.
You had a $900,000 offer
for 30%.
That evaporated down
to $90,000 for 5%.
So you talked your way
out of that one Nicely.
Daymond offered you
$1 million,
and it went to zero, because you
meandered around here
like a shark that has
no direction.
So I think,
at the end of the day,
if you keep working this hard,
you'll leave with nothing.
I was gonna offer him
$1 million, too,
and he talked himself
out of that.
(Kevin) wow.
I think you better get focused,
because now you have
two sharks left.
Mr. Cuban hasn't spoken
what he wants to do.
Right.
Lori has actually diminished
her offer dramatically
'cause she got tired
of listening to you.
(laughs) That's not why.
I think it's True.
You went back and talked
to somebody.
What are you coming back
to tell us?
Uh, so I went and talked
to my Younger brother
and got his c.E.O.
To speak to me
about the value of, uh,
a line of credit.
$10 million is a number
that we discussed.
But what amount of cash
do you want today
for what percentage?
M-more what I want is
based on the valuation.
So the--
so you'll take $90,000--
What's the--
Let him talk.
Let him talk. Let him talk.
The valuation is $15 million.
So $1.5 million for 10%
of the company, for example.
Okay. There's what you really
wanted to come in
and ask for today.
Okay.
I just want to make sure
you guys are clear.
He wants
a $15 million valuation.
Okay, I'm out again.
(mark) It took a lot of work
to get you to that valuation.
$15 million, even with knowing
that there's a floor
of $1 million
in purchase orders,
is too high
for a consumer goods product.
Okay.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Uh, is there--
Whoa. Wow.
Wait, wait.
So what's the value
that you have in mind
for the company right now?
Nowhere near $15 million,
because--
I know.
I'm happy to hear
what it is, though.
(Robert) Michael.
It doesn't matter, Michael.
I don't want--
Michael, he's out.
Lori's still in.
I'm--I'm still--
Michael, what I tried to do--
I'm still willing
to negotiate.
I understand, Michael,
but we did negotiate.
I gave you
the benefit of the doubt,
and we went through
a whole dance,
a whole negotiation.
Right.
And with that still,
you came to $15 million.
We were talking about details
that, to me,
are--Are very important
for structuring the deal,
but we weren't talking numbers,
and I--
But the most important detail
now is he's out.
So talk to Lori.
I was just--
I was just waiting--
I thought you were gonna
make an offer,
and I was just biding time.
And you were wrong, Michael.
You were wrong.
You're best to talk to Lori.
So, the--
mark, the one thing
I have for you is that the--
You're best to talk
to Lori, man.
There are 15--
Michael, what are you doing?
(indistinct arguing)
the guy said he was out.
(daymond) You have one last
person to talk to. Please.
You have--You have done
a remarkable thing.
You have convinced everybody
to rescind their offer
because you can't seem
to make a decision.
I do seem to be
the only one left here.
So you have your moment now
to convince me
why I should stay with you,
when you didn't realize that...
Mm-hmm. Right.
I was the right one for you.
My initial Strategy was simply
to field all the offers,
and I think because we got so
caught up in those discussions,
that I wasn't able to ask you
all the questions
that I wanted to originally.
Michael, what are you
doing with Lori's offer?
So what I'm asking
from you is,
in an "as seen on tv"
Campaign,
it requires buying
Inventory
before Those purchase orders
are in place.
No, actually, it doesn't.
But that's why I was
the right partner,
because I told you I know
all about what you need.
But still, the valuation...
I'm not pleased with.
Well, if we went back to
your original $90,000 for 5%...
Mm-Hmm?
What if I were to give you
$90,000 for 10%?
All of it's here for you.
It's all here.
Mm-hmm.
Perfectly.
Like, tied up in a bow.
I just tuned out
for a little bit because--
You tuned out?!
(daymond) He tuned you out,
Lori, for a little bit.
(laughs)
I just thought--I mean,
you're obviously the shark
and trying to take advantage
of the situation--
(daymond) No, you're not.
No, I'm not trying
to take advantage.
He just said
he tuned you out.
That's--No--
Not in a--
not in a disrespectful way.
Well, you--
Just a breather--
Yeah, take a breath.
Take a breath.
Ask yourself--
Michael, how do you say
something like that
respectfully?
I--
Ask yourself--
How is it going
in the "shark tank"
for you right now?
(laughs)
How's it going, Buddy?
Uh, far more intense
than I anticipated.
(Robert) Michael, you've played
this game for a long time now.
You know, you've been
disrespectful to Lori.
She's made you an offer.
What are you going to do?
Uh, I'd like to make
a counteroffer.
Why don't you talk to her?
All right. Absolutely.
Okay.
Lori, So, uh,
I would like to sign
an agreement
for a 5% equity stake.
So, if any of the sharks
would like to re-Enter
and make
a simple cash offer
for a 5% equity stake
so we can be--
the $90,000 at 5%?
So--No. I-I'm saying,
who will bid the highest?
(scoffs)
Michael, it doesn't work
that way!
(daymond) You are
playing games.
It doesn't work that way!
None of us are interested
except for Lori.
Are you gonna take
her offer or not?
Michael, I'm giving you
a lifeline
for the next--Literally--
Two seconds.
This is the last thing
I'm gonna offer you.
$90,000, 8%.
Take it or leave it.
(exhales deeply)
time to make a decision,
Michael.
(clears throat)
(Lori) You should know
in your gut.
I-I'll do it.
You got a deal.
All right. Good.
Wow.
Yeah, finally!
(all speaking at once)
Thank you. I'm really--
I am really happy
to have a deal done.
All right, good.
Good to hear.
Congratulations, Michael.
All right. Michael.
Thanks, guys. Thank you.
Thank you.
Bye.
I got a deal.
(groans)
I'm shocked
you stayed in it.
You know, I like
the product, guys.
I can't stand him.
Platetopper bozo.
(Lori) I did what I wanted
to do.
It's a good product.
(singsongy)
I'm gonna make it a hero!